Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous.
Est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé,
au travail ou à votre école,
que la machine à café fonctionne mal ?
Vous voulez du café,
elle vous donne de l’eau.
Vous ne voulez pas de sucre,
elle vous donne du sucre.
Moi, ça m’est arrivé
il n’y a pas trop longtemps.
Le café a coulé juste à côté de ma tasse.
Mais j’avais de la chance,
il y avait le réparateur qui était là.
Je lui dis : « Monsieur, à cette machine,
le café coule juste à côté de la tasse. »
Et, c’est incroyable, il me répond :
« Non, non, ça ne coule pas à côté. »
Alors j’insiste un peu :
« Si, je vous assure, cette machine-là,
je viens d’y aller,
le café a coulé à côté de la tasse.
Il y en avait un peu dedans,
beaucoup à côté,
et ma tasse est toute collante. »
Et encore une fois,
c’est incroyable, il me dit :
« Non, non, ça ne coule pas à côté. »
Alors j'ai laissé tomber.
À mon avis, la façon dont il m’a
dit non n’était pas appropriée.
Et c’est de cela dont j’ai envie
de vous parler ce soir,
de la façon appropriée de dire non.
Comment dire non ?
Et surtout comment dire oui ?
Parce qu’il y a plein de formations,
et plein de bouquins sur comment dire non,
mais finalement il n’y a quasiment rien
sur comment dire oui.
Et pourtant, ce n’est pas
toujours facile de dire oui,
surtout quand on est décisionnaire.
Je vais vous montrer
trois façons de dire oui,
et vous allez voir, dire oui,
ça ouvre le champ des possibles.
En France, on est les champions
du monde du non.
C'est vrai, les Français adorent dire non.
On manifeste quasiment non-stop
depuis qu’on a pris la Bastille.
On se souvient tous
de notre première manif.
Moi, c'était contre la loi Devaquet.
En plus, je n’étais pas vraiment contre,
mais j’avais seize ans
et j’aimais déjà bien dire non.
En France aussi,
on est le seul pays au monde
à avoir des cours
de philosophie obligatoires
pour tous les élèves
au lycée en terminale.
C’est génial
parce qu’on a tous appris à avoir
une réflexion critique sur notre monde.
En philosophie, on apprend à faire
des dissertations selon le modèle
« thèse antithèse synthèse ».
C’est-à-dire qu’on apprend à exposer
nos arguments dans la thèse,
ensuite à contre-argumenter
dans l’antithèse
et ensuite à faire une sorte
de résumé dans la synthèse.
Vous imaginez,
on a tous appris à dire non à notre
propre opinion, c’est dingue.
(Rires)
Alors pourquoi ? Pourquoi tout ça ?
Finalement, dire non,
c’est une invitation à débattre.
Est-ce que ça voulait dire que
mon réparateur était en fait un philosophe
et qu’il voulait débattre avec moi ?
Non, je ne crois pas.
Je crois qu'il avait trop de travail.
Le non de mon réparateur n’a pas eu
trop de conséquences, finalement.
Mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas.
Il y a vingt ans,
j’habitais à Fontenay-aux-Roses.
C’est une jolie petite ville
au sud de Paris.
Tous les matins, je prenais le RER
et je m’arrêtais à l’arrêt
Parc de Sceaux pour travailler.
Il faut le savoir,
Fontenay-aux-Roses et Parc de Sceaux
sont deux toutes petites gares.
Entre les deux, il y a 3 ou 4 stations
avec un changement à Bourg-la-Reine.
Je devais être le seul
dans toute l’Ile-de-France
à faire ce trajet-là quotidiennement.
Mes tickets de RER fonctionnaient
très bien à l’aller mais jamais au retour.
C’est-à-dire que tous les soirs, j’étais
obligé d’enjamber les tourniquets.
Au bout de deux, trois semaines
d’acrobaties comme ça,
je suis allé au guichet :
« Écoutez, monsieur, les tickets
fonctionnent très bien à l’aller
mais jamais au retour. »
Alors il vérifie mes tickets,
il regarde le registre
de maintenance des tourniquets
et il me dit : « Non, non, vos tickets
fonctionnent très bien
et les tourniquets
fonctionnent très bien. »
Alors j’ai continué
pendant quelques semaines
à faire des acrobaties tous les soirs.
Je suis retourné une deuxième,
une troisième fois au guichet.
À chaque fois, une personne
différente et à chaque fois :
« Vos tickets fonctionnent bien,
les tourniquets fonctionnent bien.
- Mais venez avec moi aux tourniquets. »
Mais ils étaient trop loin,
au bout du quai.
Bref, c’était compliqué.
Elles ont essayé de m’aider
mais n’ont pas réussi.
Au final, j'ai eu trois non
en réponse à mon problème.
Alors j’ai trouvé ma solution,
une solution illégale.
J’ai décidé de ne plus utiliser de tickets
pour mes voyages retours
puisque de toute façon, j’étais
obligé d’enjamber ces tourniquets.
J’ai fait ça pendant cinq ans, jusqu’à
ce que je déménage dans une autre ville.
De temps en temps, j’essayais un ticket
et en effet, ça ne marchait toujours pas.
Trois non m'ont autorisé à tricher.
Trois non ont eu de graves
conséquences sur moi.
Trois non ont fait de moi un tricheur.
Un soir, j’étais à une soirée privée
à Fontenay-aux-Roses.
Il y a une dame qui s’approche
de moi, qui me fait :
« Bonsoir, on ne s’est pas
déjà vu quelque part ? »
Je bombe un peu le torse :
« Ouais, peut-être à la salle de sport. »
Elle me fait : « Ah non mais ça y est,
je vous reconnais !
C’est vous qui tous les soirs, sautez
par au-dessus des tourniquets
avec votre petit costume,
votre petite cravate.
En fait, vous êtes un tricheur. »
Et moi je dis : « Ben non, enfin oui,
mais mes tickets ne fonctionnent pas.
Oui, mais je suis allé au guichet,
ils n’ont pas trouvé de solution.
Oui, mais, même avec des tickets,
je suis obligé de passer par au-dessus. »
Oui mais, oui mais, oui mais,
elle avait raison.
Et j’avais honte !
Oui mais, oui mais.
Moi aussi j’aimais bien dire « oui, mais »
comme beaucoup de personnes d’ailleurs.
« Oui, mais », pour moi, ce sont les mots
qu’un parent utilise avec son enfant.
Imaginez cette scène un samedi soir :
« Papa, je peux sortir ce soir ?
- Oui, mais ne rentre pas trop tard.
- Papa, tu me prêtes ta voiture ?
- Oui, mais ne conduis pas trop vite.
- Papa, tu me passes 20€ ? - Oui,
mais ne t’achète pas de cigarettes avec. »
« Oui mais, ne fais pas ci,
oui, mais ne fais pas ça. »
Peut-être que ça vous rappelle
des souvenirs.
Mais le problème, c’est que notre cerveau
ne comprend pas la négation.
Il ne comprend pas le « ne pas ».
« Ne pensez pas à un éléphant. »
Notre cerveau ne comprend
que l’affirmatif.
Plutôt que de dire ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire, dites plutôt ce qu'il faut faire.
C'est beaucoup plus efficace.
Au lieu de « ne rentre pas trop tard »,
dites plutôt « rentre à 23 h »,
« ne conduis pas trop vite »,
« conduis prudemment »,
« ne t’achète pas de cigarettes »,
« achète-toi un bon repas ».
Maintenant, dans le cas précis
des mauvaises idées,
est-ce qu’on ne peut pas dire :
« Oui mais ne fais pas ça ! » ?
Alors tout d’abord,
pour moi, toutes les idées,
même les plus mauvaises,
méritent de vivre,
ne serait-ce que quelques minutes.
Ensuite, j’évite de dire « Oui, mais »
je préfère dire « Oui, et ».
Sur Internet, il y a des millions
de mauvaises idées.
J'ai trouvé un métronome qui bat
la mesure de façon irrégulière.
Si on me demande mon avis, je peux dire :
« Oui, mais ce n’est pas
le rôle d’un métronome.
Il doit battre la mesure
de façon régulière. »
Mais je préfère dire :
« Oui, c’est génial !
Et ça permet de donner une touche
de modernité très facilement
à n’importe quel morceau classique. »
Un « oui, et » au lieu d’un « oui, mais »,
ça encourage l’innovation.
Encourageons !
Encourageons nos proches, encourageons,
encourageons, encourageons.
Il y a aussi une autre façon que j’aime
faire, c’est être l’avocat de l’ange.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez.
L’avocat de l’ange, en fait,
il trouve toujours le bon côté
à une idée ou à un projet.
En général, je dis toujours
trois choses positives
et ensuite je pose une question.
Il y a une de mes étudiantes
qui devait interviewer
une personne de son entreprise - c’était
une alternante - sur l’externalisation.
Elle voulait que je relise
la liste de ses questions.
La première question, c’était « Quelle
est votre stratégie d’externalisation ? »
Pour moi, ce n’est pas une bonne question,
une bonne première question en tout cas.
J’aurais pu lui dire : « Oui, c’est bien,
mais ne commence pas comme ça. »
Mais j’ai préféré faire
l’avocat de l’ange :
« Oh, je suis impressionné que tu
aies réussi à interviewer
le numéro un de l’externalisation
dans ta société.
Tes questions sur les problèmes
de communication avec les prestataires
sont vraiment très pertinentes.
J’aime beaucoup la façon dont
tu réduis le cadre de tes questions
sur un certain type de prestataires. »
Et ensuite la question :
« Pourquoi commences-tu
ton interview par la question
‘Quelle est votre stratégie
d’externalisation ?’ »
En fait, jouer l’avocat de l’ange,
c’est plus encourageant.
Et c’est ça en fait : il faut encourager.
Il faut encourager nos proches,
nos élèves, nos amis.
Il faut encourager les chercheurs.
Il faut encourager
tous ceux qui ont des idées.
Je vous propose qu’on fasse là maintenant,
tous ensemble, une expérience.
Alors vous le savez,
je suis Dorian Di Betta.
Je travaille en R&D
dans l’industrie pharmaceutique.
Maintenant, imaginez.
Je suis Katalin Kariko, chercheuse
dans un laboratoire de recherche.
Pour que l’expérience fonctionne,
j’ai besoin que vous disiez « oui »
après chacune de mes phrases.
Bien sûr, si vous ne vous sentez pas
l’envie de dire « oui », ne dites rien.
J’ai une super idée,
je peux vous la dire ?
Public : Oui !
L’ARN messager provoque de
très fortes réactions immunitaires.
Et si je modifie un tout petit peu
cette molécule pour diminuer cet effet,
est-ce que vous pensez
que c’est une bonne idée ?
Public : Oui.
J’ai fait cette petite modification
et ça a marché.
Et si on déposait un brevet,
vous êtes d’accord ?
Public : Oui.
Cellscript veut nous racheter le brevet
et développer cette nouvelle technologie
à des fins thérapeutiques.
Nous, ça, on ne sait pas faire.
Du coup, on leur vend ?
Public : Oui.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup pour tous vos oui.
Pour finir cette belle histoire,
Cellscript a vendu ce brevet à Moderna
et grâce à ce brevet,
Moderna a inventé le premier vaccin
à ARN Messager de l’Histoire.
En fait, c’est grâce à des décennies
et des décennies d’encouragements
qu’on a aujourd’hui une nouvelle façon
plus rapide de faire des vaccins,
une nouvelle façon
de lutter contre la maladie.
Maintenant, on va refaire
la même expérience,
mais au lieu de me dire oui,
vous allez me dire non.
J’ai une super idée,
je peux vous la dire ?
Public : Non.
Non ?
Ah ben, je ne vous demanderai
plus jamais rien.
En fait, ce que je voulais vous dire
avec cette petite expérience,
c’est quand une personne
vous expose son projet, son idée,
et que vous lui dites non,
vous avez le risque que cette personne
ne vous demande plus jamais rien,
qu’elle fasse tout dans son coin
sans votre contrôle, sans vos conseils.
Ce qui est embêtant
si vous êtes son manager.
Vous avez aussi le risque
qu’elle se démotive, qu’elle abandonne,
ce qui est embêtant
si c’était une bonne idée
et même le risque même
qu’elle quitte la société.
Un seul non tue l’innovation.
C'est facile de dire non.
C’est beaucoup plus facile
de dire non que de dire oui.
C'est beaucoup moins risqué
quand on est décideur.
J’ai demandé autour de moi
à des personnes décisionnaires
comment elles disaient oui ou non.
Je n’ai pas demandé à ce genre
de personnes qui disent non
parce que quand elles disent non,
elles se sentent fortes, puissantes.
J'ai eu des réponses parfois surprenantes.
Quelqu’un m’a dit : « Ha, moi,
je dis toujours non parce que c’est
plus facile de changer un non en oui
qu’un oui en non. »
J'ai trouvé ça tordu.
Une autre m’a dit :
« Ah moi, je ne dis jamais non.
Je dis l’année prochaine »,
sachant très bien que l’année prochaine,
il dira encore l’année prochaine.
Je trouve ça cruel.
Quant à moi, est-ce
que je ne dis jamais non ? Non.
Par exemple, je dis non
quand on présente un projet
et que les risques
n’ont pas été assez évalués.
Quant à vous, la prochaine fois que
vous êtes sur le point de dire non
ou « oui, mais »,
repensez à mon talk.
Vous avez trois façons de communiquer :
dire « oui, et »
au lieu de dire « oui, mais »,
dites ce qu’il faut faire au lieu
de dire ce qu’il ne faut pas faire,
ou bien faites l’avocat de l’ange.
Et souvenez-vous : le oui que vous donnez,
ou même le oui que vous vous donnez,
peut mener à la réussite.
Merci. (Applaudissements)